tout le monde est là
c'est super impressionnant
je pense qu'on devrait essayer de savoir
où on se trouve sur la carte exactement
il faut qu'on soit prêt tout ce qui peut
nous attendre non
que connaissez-vous du combat je sers
produire des figures de 4 qu'on nous
conseille de pas imité chez soi voilà
prenez votre site
sachez qu'un libéral mais tout n'est pas
ouvert
tout le monde participe pour gagner tu
fais confiance à toute ton équipe
la magie des verts allemands
partout
regardez un quart des parents
c'est quoi ça
seul vous autres non natifs de ce
royaume pouvait rétablir le lien
craquerez entrée moral mais les parcs le
labyrinthe est composée de huit entrées
et d'une seule sortie
[Applaudissements]
je pense que le plus important à la fin
ce ne sera pas de gagner
punaise je me demande comment je suis
sûr positif
et maintenant la quête que commencer
demande où ils vont avec nous genre
c'est des ados qui vont nous aider à
sauver le royaume il ne sous-estime
seulement sur dix n'est plus